foreign
25 30 and you think you should have your
whole life figured out that's ludicrous
when you're this young the number one
thing you should do is the most high
risk behavior of your life this is
exactly when you should go live in Bali
for a year this is exactly when you try
to become Beyonce this is exactly when
you do the highest risk the biggest
thing I want for everybody in this room
is to do random go put out a song
take in your 20s you got a taste
it's no different than kissing a bunch
of frogs until you find your prince the
people that will cast judgment on
someone who's still trying to explore
are people who themselves settled
without exploring they're not intending
to be mean tear you down stop you
conform you into settling like they did
but that's exactly what they're doing
Society is incredibly subconsciously
interested in you conforming don't